This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. We have an exciting, exciting guest today for a very exciting topic. We do the series on the show called Dating in Your 20s and our guest has decided to join us and share some of her own wisdom. Violet, how are you going? I'm well. Thank you so much for having me. I'm excited to be here. Yeah, of course. It felt like such a natural fit, honestly. So Violet, if you do not know her, is the host of the Almost Adelting podcast, otherwise known as Daddy Issues online, some amazing advice given over there and just like some hard truth skilled. So I feel like this is going to be a great episode. Yeah, I'm excited. Thank you.
Yeah, we got, we got really, we got on really well before we started recording. So that was, that's always good. Yeah. Well, I felt like we were sitting in like the zoom talking because you're in LA. Yes. Yeah, and I'm in Sydney. And we were sitting on the Zoom. I think for like half an hour, just actually just having having a yarn, as they say in Australia, having a little chat. Um, so I was like, about to support facts. Everyone's open your ears wide. That's so cute. Okay, your phrases. I could tell you, Australia, the minute you said the word heaps when we're talking in DMs. I'm like, okay, so you're in Australia. What, what is it? Heaps? Yeah, you said heaps. There's heaps something.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, I totally say that. So it's so funny because I don't notice it until I'm on calls with people who are based in the US or based in London. And they'll be like, what did you just say? And I'm like, I don't know. I also got this like random DM from someone the other day that was like, you pronounce all of your words incorrectly. Like, and I was like, yeah, she was. And then she like was like, these are the words that I heard in your most recent episode that
were wrong. And I was like, I've got an Australian accent. Like it's not. I know. Yeah. It was so strange. No, it's a real thing. I have gotten before negative reviews on my almost adulting.
podcast and mean DMs, when people get upset with me, when I don't pronounce myself, when I pronounce someone's name or word incorrectly, even though English is my third language, people forget that whatever countries you're from, you end up pronouncing words differently. Yeah, exactly. Americans forget that. Yeah. That's so interesting as well, considering that English is your third language. Yes. Like, come on, give you, be nice about it. I feel like if they also spoke three plus languages, they are welcome to criticize. But if not, yeah, it's kind of like if you were trying to speak French right now, because of how you grew up speaking English with your Australian accent, you will not be able to have the proper accent that French people have. Because I speak Hebrew,
I have the perfect French accent when I speak French, and I'm able to mimic it perfectly. But Americans will not be able either. And I will be able to say a lot of words, but that you guys won't be able to because of how I grew up. So it's the same thing. then people from other, to speak other languages, can't pronounce her in English words, because we've never learned how to pronounce it like that or our mouths don't move in that way. I don't know how to explain it. There's just words, some words that we just won't be able to ever pronounce. I'm not even going to try and do that ar sound that you just did.
I feel like it's going to be so embarrassing because I unfortunately only speak one language. Anyhow, look at that. We're already off on like a massive tangent. What we're really here to talk about today is dating. in your 20s and I feel like you have a lot of wisdom. Even before we jumped on this call, you were saying you're in like a long-term relationship for most of your 20s, aren't you?
Yes, I was. I was in, wouldn't it be funny by just thinking. If I was one of those guests, he asked me a question, I'd just say yes. Yeah, go for you. Oh my God,
I'd be working hard. Okay, so yes, I was in a relationship, most of my 20s. I was on and off with my second boyfriend. I basically growing up and I started dating when I was 17. I was very much a late bloomer. I wasn't interested in boys. I moved to America when I was 14.
I was just trying to figure out how to speak English. And it was not even thinking about boys. I did not get them at all, especially Americans and in Los Angeles right away. It's a whole different world with those kids. And I had my own issues growing up aside from, I was more with birth defects. It gave me a lot of insecurity as I stayed away from boys until late teenage years, but also I grew up, as I'm known as daddy issues. I grew up with daddy issues when I go through my teenage life. So of course, that subconsciously formed the way I started pursuing my partners.
I didn't know this yet. You don't know this as a child and you don't know this as an adult that a lot of the pattern of who you date has a lot to do with your childhood. trauma. You don't realize that yet. So the guy that I was just, it wasn't love, it was obsession. He was my drug. And I didn't know why he was my drug, but I was addicted to him. I was addicted to my relationship for eight years. It was on and off and he was just my everything. I mean, when, when every time we break up, I, I would not, it almost felt like I couldn't breathe. I was a person that I didn't want to get out of bed until he spoke to me, until I knew, were going to be okay. It just felt he was my everything. And of course, when you have those type of
partners, they love it. But guess the type of person I ended up attracting emotionally unavailable partner. Did I realize that? No, of course I didn't. I just needed him to love me. And for eight years, it was this constant chase, maybe one day he will love me. And I did everything I could to be better for him. For eight years, I was shaved my body every single day. As long as we were together, my body shaved every single day. I want to be beautiful for him. Did he still? Did he still? cheat on me all the time? Yes. Did I know? No, because I secretly didn't want to know. I secretly didn't want to know that because I think I didn't then want to deal with what would happen if I found out because then I would actually have to leave and that's a whole other thing. Did I love
myself when I was growing up? No, of course not because if I did, I wouldn't have stayed in that relationship. But I think everything that happens to us, including people we date, it's not in a way that you look back and you think, I can't believe I gave him all my 20s. I can't believe I did this. It's more That was a life lesson. And the reason I stayed with my partner for so long was because the universe was teaching me over and over again the same mistakes that I was just for some reason not learning. And it wasn't until I'd learned how to love myself that I removed myself in that relationship and start working on myself. Do I have some regrets that a part of me wishes I didn't give so many of my 20s to someone? Just one person, yes.
But that's what I needed in my path to learn. I wish I didn't only exit that relationship in my late 20s and early 30s. And that was the first time I learned how to date or I had to unlearn everything I thought love was. I had to unlearn what I like, what I don't like. Because when I got up with that relationship with him, I tried to date guys afterwards. And I would pick fights with them thinking that was going to make us closer. I would pick fights to get that tension because that's what I grew up with my dad when I was. I was young, where my dad forgets I exist. So I have to act out. And when I act out, even if he beats
the shit of me, at least he notices me. So then accidentally in my relationship, end up being the same thing where we would fight, and that's when my boyfriend pay attention to me, and then we're fine. That was so insightful. I was so, so insightful. And I think it really goes to show the complex interaction between how we were raised and how we approach intimacy and romantic relationships. And I think people often don't think that those are linked, right? They're like, okay, well, you know, my childhood was a discreet time in my life, and my adulthood or my adolescence is also a discrete time. And there's no overlap.
But it's like you really are still the same person that's traveled through all of those experiences and the trauma that you take from those will be brought into every chapter of your life. What do you think it was about your attachment style or how you were raised or your childhood that led you to be attracted to emotionally unavailable people. Okay, so here's the thing. A lot of people when they listen, they think, well, I don't have daddy issues that I can't relate, but they may have mommy issues,
or they think I grew up with both of my parents together, or I grew up with our parents, or whatever your dynamic and you're growing up is, you'll be surprised, but everyone has some type of childhood trauma without even realize it. And trauma is not as bad of a word as people think it is. It just means it's what formed you into the human being, the adult that you are.
or they think I grew up with both of my parents together, or I grew up with our parents, or whatever your dynamic and your growing up is, you'll be surprised, but everyone has some type of childhood trauma without even realize it. And trauma is not as bad of a word as people think it is. It just means it's what formed you into the human being, the adult that you are.
And it's up to you now as an adult to unlearn a lot of these things. So again, even if you think, well, my dad was really nice to me. So was my mom. Let's say there's guys out there. Their mom loved them so much. Guess what? They have mommy issues where they now attract women like their mother and they hate them. They're repulsed by them because they feel suffocated and it reminds them of their mother.
So then they end up chasing women who don't love them. So everyone has their own weird type of dating stuff that has to do with your parents until you realize it's happening and you have to learn it. But you have to be self-aware. So I attracted my partner who I was obsessed with who was my second boyfriend because my first one were just chilling, but my second one was like a drug. Because he was emotionally unavailable, which was similar to my father. And the reason we end up attract these type of partners, not just emotionally and available. anything that feels familiar. Anytime in your life you meet someone and one person you meet and you're like, okay, maybe I'll go out with them a few times.
Maybe I like them. Then someone else you mean and you're like, whoa, I like you. What is this feeling? I don't get it. But if I love it and it's because it feels familiar. And the reason I feel familiar is because it's a childhood wound that you have inside yourself that hasn't healed. and your body feels at home, but not in a good way, in a way that something hurt you when you were a child. And that's what's reminding you of.
And what's happening is, this is the psychology behind it. We attract partners that are similar to our childhood traumas or our parents when they hurt us, because it's your brain hoping to revisit the same situation that happened to you in the past, and it's hoping that the outcome will be different this time. So if my father was emotional and available, which he was growing up, but because I didn't understand his love language yet. So nothing I say is in a way where I want anyone to feel sorry for me because I've worked through that.
For me, my father was emotionally unavailable. He didn't know express his feelings. And he didn't hug me or kiss me until it was 24, 25. And that's because I changed the cycle in our family because I made that choice. But until I decide to make that choice, I was dating guys like my dad, including my ex. So I started dating a man who was also emotionally unavailable. And my brain was hoping maybe eventually this guy will love you. So even though when you were growing up as a kid, your dad didn't love you,
this man will finally give you the validation that you've been searching for years. And guess what? It didn't happen. Because no matter what I did, I wasn't enough. Or that's what it felt like. Because love first has to start with you. That's the longest relationship you're going to have in your life. It's a relationship you have with yourself.
You can't continuously seek this outside, outside love. if you don't love yourself because you don't know, not to mention, I don't know what love is. I grew up with a dad who didn't kiss me or hug me or tell me he loves me. What do I know what love is? I see my dad being cold. I think that's love. So that's what I attract. Just like I have friends that grew up in a very abusive households where their parents were fighting all the time.
They end up attracting a partner that they're fighting with all the time. They think that's love. So many of us don't realize, but we don't even know what love is. I agree. Honestly, and especially as people in our 20s, I think love for us is sometimes just a feeling and we think that it's passion and we think that it's chaos or we think that it should just be this like easy thing. And we really don't know because I think just like trauma, love is also incredibly subjective. But it's interesting that you talk about how you like shifted the dynamic because I feel like when I've done a lot of work with my own therapist around my attachment style and and all that comes with that.
think it doesn't just have to do with your parental relationships. You know, as a child, I was really bullied, was really badly bullied. And I never really felt like anyone liked me that I was like wanted or desired as a friend. And then as I got like later into my adolescence as someone people wanted to date. And so as soon as I went to university and like people were like attracted to me and there was alcohol and I was, there was all this freedom and I was living in college. I had no standards for myself because I was like, well, I have this inner childhood wound of not feeling wanted and feeling unlovable. So the moment that someone comes in and is like, you know, even just wants to have sex with you, they don't want to give you anything more. My brain was like, well, that's showing that
they want you and that's like a really, that's something that you've always wanted. That's something that you're really like you've always desired. And wouldn't it be amazing? to finally have that. So I basically just didn't have any standards for myself and would attract people who treated me badly or who were like almost cruel or super ambivalent towards like our relationship. I don't know how to you. You didn't know what love was. Of course, of course you equated that to love because you did you said I felt unlovable. People didn't want to be my friends. And and the thing is that was the reality you create to yourself. And when we feel that way about ourselves, it doesn't matter what's happening on the outside. We don't see it. And eventually you grow up and
you realize, wow, all these people around me are trying to love me. And I'm not even seeing it because I'm so focused on the people who don't love me because I grew up feeling unlovable. So again, you don't know love it. So then you only then end up being drawn to people who don't love you or you end up being drawn to someone that even for a night gives you sex because in that moment you feel desirable and you feel wanted. And I, for the longest time with my ex-boyfriend, all we had really is sex. We didn't really talk. I didn't know how to open up to people. I never talked about my feelings. So I did, even though that was my one partner sexually, all I had to offer him was my body. I wanted to be beautiful for him. I was having sex with him. So I also equated sex with love. And that's the
thing that a lot of women do. And I've tried to talk about that before. And of course, some people may not agree with my opinion when I say hold off on sex. But I believe it's genuinely important, especially if you're someone who still has to figure out your emotions and your mental health and to put yourself first and to learn how to love yourself. If you accidentally fall in love through sex, which has been a thing for me, then hold off because you want to get to know somebody on an emotional level before you catch up to it in a physical level. But you asked me something else and I'm sorry that I ended up forgetting what you were talking about. honestly it just shows that you're passionate and I feel like that this is just I know I love it it's like honestly so refreshing but it's interesting I just want to quickly talk on this um I was looking into this research the other day sex creates like an emotional and neural bond with someone not saying that that doesn't mean yeah for women is like in particular and I'm not saying that that doesn't mean you can have as much casual sex as you want but it's worth noting.
that when you are physically close with someone in that manner, whatever sex is for you in that moment, the amount of like oxytocin, which is like the chemical associated with happiness, but also bonding that is released, it's no wonder that so many people, I think, find themselves, they've had sex with someone and then suddenly they're like, oh my God, I'm attached. You've got to also know what you want. Like I started doing this thing where I realized that I was very actively going for people who I actually didn't even respect or have anything in common with because I was like, oh, you know, well, then they'll never leave me and I'll feel loved. And it basically like retrained my brain
into not feeling that I actually deserve the love that I wanted. So now I like have, I like went to my therapist and was like, this is happening. I keep getting like obsessed over these men who I don't even respect. You still get obsessed over them. Not anymore. This was like back, maybe like a year and a half ago. I like went to her and was like, I'm like, there would be men who were violent. Like they would be like, so less. Like literally. One of them was, was living with his, like living out of his car and with his friends.
No shame to that. Like people go through different life circumstances. And he broke up with you and he said, you know what? I think I can do better. Oh, yeah, probably. Like, I think he, it was a long relationship. But like, there was another one who's like, he's like, I still live at home with my mom. and I hate my job, but I only work three days a week.
And I have no, I was like, what are you interested in? And he's like, I don't really know, like, watching TV. And I was like, I was like, are you the love of my life? Because it's like, if you don't have hobbies, I can be your hobby. I can be your hobby. Because I'm interested in me. Yeah. And the other thing was like, he couldn't drive.
And I was like, I can teach him how to drive. And then, you know what? He can depend on me. Exactly. It was, it was toxic. And like, I can look at that now. and be like, I get that. I get where that was coming from.
I get why that was bad because I've healed that part of myself. But the way that I did that was like, I literally set out like point blank in my notes. I wrote it in my diary like, what is the bare minimum here? Like, what do I want? And after like dates, I would go back and be like, did they actually need this? If I like couldn't really tell, I would go on a second date. But if it was like, no, then I was like, I always messaged them being like, I'm really, like, I had a really amazing time, but this isn't going anywhere.
And it's like a massive thing you need to learn. So I think my question to you was like, what do you think that, what do you wish you'd known at that time? Or what do you wish you'd known earlier as someone back in their 20s? Well, A, I wish, it's hard to say because a part of me wants to say, I wish I learned how I love myself sooner. But then I also think I needed to have all these life lessons. But I guess if I was being unrealistic and more dream in dreamland, And as a scopier. Yes, if I could have the same outcome as now, if nothing would change, if something that I could wish that I learned faster is probably how to love myself and how to walk away from a partner that was never going to love me because it was never about that person.
And I wish that I didn't, you know what actually I wish? I wish that I would have been more brave and learn and change my gender. generational trauma and my family's dynamic sooner. Because so many years, I was always so afraid of being rejected by my father, which sounds so silly for anyone out there that doesn't have the type of issues, whether it's your mother or your father. But it's this weird rejection because people don't realize if you have that issues, the first man that breaks your heart, technically is your father, which is a little strange. But I didn't really grow up with him. And then I remember when I saw one of my friends hug my dad, I didn't understand why she even did that. And I was like, wait, you just asked your dad for advice and you guys just hug just like that. That's so weird. She goes, do you not hug your dad? And I go, well, I don't even know what he would do. But if I tried to hug him and he was like, ew, why are you touching me? That's so not our dynamic. It's weird. So it took me years until, and I never would say I love you to him because I was scared. He would laugh in my face or he would reject me. And I was scared of the rejection. And that kind of created.
the rest of my identity, where it was around the male gaze, where I was insecure enough that I stay with my ex for so long. And I was, I was just there to be pretty and have sex with my boyfriend while he was cheating on me. But that was my role. And I still didn't know who I was. So when I one day, as an account, I used to be an accountant. Oh, that's why. Yeah. I have two degrees. So I used to be an accountant. That's one of my degrees at a big public accounting firm. And when I was a, I was an accountant. I was getting bullied at that firm. It's actually one of the reasons I started daddy issues. So honestly, bless them for bullying.
the rest of my identity, where it was around the male gaze, where I was insecure enough that I stay with my ex for so long. And I was, I was just there to be pretty and have sex with my boyfriend while he was cheating on me. But that was my role. And I still didn't know who I was. So when I one day, as an accountant, I used to be an accountant. Oh, that's why. Yeah. I have two degrees. So I used to be an accountant. That's one of my degrees at a big public accounting firm. And when I was a, I was an accountant. I was getting bullied at that firm. It's actually one of the reasons I started daddy issues. So honestly, bless them for bullying.
Yeah. Thank you so much. Thank you for making me so strong. I wonder how they're going. Yeah. How are you going, friends? So because of that, I created daddy issues secretly. And daddy issues when I created it.
And I got to see with just through memes that my and when I created daddy issues, I created an alter ego because at this point, I had no idea who I was. And I felt so invisible, I had no identity. And the people created. me because when I started posting random things anonymously, because I was anonymous for almost two years, is when I suddenly got to see, oh, other people can't relate. Oh, I thought I was alone in this. Okay. And that gave me the confidence. And when I created that issues, I wrote about a girl who was my alter ego because I could never be as cool as her. She was a popular girl. She was a skinny,
pretty girl that everyone liked. She grew up for rich. I grew up poor. She had all the money. She did all the drugs. All the boys liked her. I was so invisible. Or at least that was my view. That was my reality. And that's how I was able to have the confidence to run daddy issues, which is so funny, because I was pretending to be her. And that gave me, and seeing how people could relate that I'm not alone, it gave me the confidence in the first time my life that I said, you know what, I don't care anymore if my dad's going to reject me because I want to tell him that I love him. Because my father may not have it as, who knows how many more years I have with him. I want him to know that I love him. And that's all that matters. And I want to hug my dad. And I'm okay.
if he says no or because at least I tried so because at least then he'll know that I love him. So I started doing that. It was a practice. I started I started on the phone when we about to talk on the phone barely, but we're about to hang up and I would say, wait, dad, hold on. He's like, what? I'm like, I love you. And it's like, silent. He hang ups. Then eventually I'm like, way, dad, I love you. Silence stays on the phone, say the phone hangs up. Then eventually, Dad, I love you. Silence. Me too. Hang up. Then eventually, I love you. I love you too. I know. It's so sweet. That is really sweet. Yeah. And then eventually started, you know, trying to hug each other and all that. And now my whole family dynamic is so different.
And in a weird way, that helped me learn how to love myself and I helped me stop feeling this. Bless you. Sorry, I get so sensitive about my dad's stuff. That's okay. It helped me stop fearing. Like my dad's love was the scariest thing to me. So once I wasn't scared of being rejected by my father, it almost felt like I was free. Because even in that moment, I would have known whether or not he was going to reciprocate. And if he didn't, I would have finally let it go.
And if he did, whatever. But in that moment also is when I got to learn love languages and all that and attach myself. And I got to learn that my father did try his whole life to love me. I just didn't know because my dad's love language was putting a roof over my head and an acts of service. Because his father was an alcoholic drunk who got beat up to death when he was, my dad was 17 for being a Jew in communist Russia. And he left my father and his mother with nothing. So my dad's for it to never be like his father to provide us with a home and get me through school. And that's exactly what he did. That's how he showed me his love. But I didn't know because I'm just a child. I just want to be hugged. And I don't have
that. But he didn't grow up with that. So as an adult, I got to learn that and I got to forgive my father for not knowing any better. And I got to show him love and he gets to give me love back. And I get to show love to the world. And that's actually one of the reasons I created my podcast because it was me being so fascinating, curious about all these things I didn't grow up with. And it made me want to, as I'm learning everything, I want to share it with my audience. Oh, that's so beautiful. It really is. And, A massive testament to you that I think not many people have the self-awareness and the vulnerability to actually approach that issue within their family.
但这并不是。但他长大时并没有得到这些。所以作为成年人，我开始学习这些，并原谅了我的父亲，因为他当时并不懂得更好。我学会向他表达爱，他也回馈我爱。我学会向世界表达爱。这其实也是我创建播客的原因之一，因为我对所有这些我成长过程中没有接触过的事物充满了好奇。这让我产生了一种愿望，在自己学习这一切的同时，我想把它分享给我的听众。哦，这太美好了。确实如此。这真的是对你极大的证明，我认为没有多少人具备这种自我意识和脆弱感，去真正面对他们家庭内部的那个问题。
Like so many people just kind of get to the point where they're like, this is how it's always going to be. But you fully changed, like you healed your generational trauma. Like you genuinely did that. As a single individual, you sat back and were like, this is mine to fix and you did it. And that's like, oh, it's so deserving. You're so deserving of that as well. And what do you think when, I really want to pick up on what you talked about when you talked about love languages as well. Do you need a minute? Do you want to pause for a second? No, I'm fine. Okay. Are you sure?
就像很多人只是到了某个阶段，觉得事情就会一直这样下去。但你完全改变了，就像你治愈了你的代际创伤。你真的做到了这一点。作为独立的个体，你退后一步，心想，这是我要去修复的问题，而你真的做到了。这真的太……你完全配得上这一切。当你谈到爱语时，我真的很想深入探讨一下。你需要休息一下吗？你想暂停一会儿吗？不，我很好。好吧。你确定吗？
I'm getting my period. Stop. Oh, okay. Do you think that knowing what you now know about your dad's love language has changed your love over time or changed how you approach, how you communicate or show your love language? So I think as we get older, our love languages are constantly changing as we are constantly evolving, hopefully, which is what you should be doing. And I think the coolest thing about love languages is that we don't realize two things. Number one, the love languages that you have as an adult, actually the love languages you didn't get as a child. Yes, fully. So my love languages were touch and words of affirmation.
我要来例假了。等等。哦，好吧。你觉得，现在了解了你父亲的爱语之后，是否改变了你随着时间推移对爱的理解，或者改变了你接近、沟通或表达爱的方式？所以我觉得随着我们年龄的增长，我们的爱语也在不断变化，前提是我们也在不断进化，希望如此，这也是你应该做的事。我觉得爱语最酷的地方在于，我们往往意识不到两件事。第一，你作为成年人拥有的爱语，其实正是你小时候没有得到的爱语。是的，完全如此。所以我的爱语是身体接触和肯定的话语。
But I didn't know that was my love languages, but that's what I lacked. And the love languages I was giving to other people were gifts and acts of service because that's what I grew up with with my father. And the second thing that we don't know about love languages, aside from it's always changing. So I guess the second thing is that it's always changing.
但我当时并不知道那是我的爱语，那正是我所缺乏的。而我给予别人的爱语却是礼物和服务的行动，因为那是我在父亲身边时耳濡目染的。关于爱语，除了它总是在变化之外，我们不知道的第二件事。所以我想第二件事就是它一直在变。
So then the third thing, we don't realize, love languages apply to everything. And a lot of times we tend to apply them only in dating. And then how often that we have breakups with our friends. And that's a thing that we never really talk about. Friendship breakups and the friends. But love language has also happened in your friendships,
然后第三件我们没有意识到的是，爱语适用于一切。很多时候，我们往往只把它们应用在约会中。然后我们和朋友分手的情况有多常见呢。这也是我们从未真正讨论过的事情。友谊的破裂和朋友之间的……但爱语其实也会发生在你和朋友的关系中，
in your family dynamic with my sister. My sister and I, during the pandemic, we had a really big fight. And I just couldn't get it. She called me selfish and all these words. And she said, you just don't love me. It feels like you don't care about me. And I said, I don't understand. I'm trying so hard to show you that I love you.
在你和姐妹的家庭关系中。在大流行期间，我和我姐姐吵了一架。我当时真的无法理解。她叫我自私，还说了各种各样的话。她说，你根本不爱我。感觉你一点也不在乎我。我说，我不明白。我一直在努力向你证明我爱你。
Every day I text you, how amazing you are. are and how much you're killing it. And I've been buying your children gifts because I love you so much. She goes, you're so fucking shallow. Like, it's like you never answer my text. You don't call me. Then you just tell me I'm amazing. Like, what does I even mean?
我每天都给你发信息，告诉你你有多棒，你做得有多出色。我还一直给你的孩子买礼物，因为我太爱你了。她说，你真是肤浅透顶。就像你从来不回我信息。你都不打电话给我。然后你只是告诉我我很棒。这到底是什么意思？
And that's when I sat down instead of attacking my sister back and not speaking to her, whatever people like to do these days. I realize, wait, why would she say I'm shallow? I don't get it. I'm showing you that I love her. And then I realize, wait, does she not feel? a love by me. What does this mean? And then I started digging into love languages. And I realized, oh, I bet we have different love languages. I bet I'm doing my best to show her that I love
就在那时，我坐了下来，没有反击我的姐姐，也没有不理她，不像现在大家喜欢做的那样。我意识到，等等，她为什么说我肤浅？我不明白。我在向她证明我爱她。然后我意识到，等等，难道她没有感受到我对她的爱吗？这是什么意思？然后我开始深入研究爱语。我意识到，哦，我敢打赌我们的爱语不同。我敢打赌，我一直在尽我最大努力向她表达我的爱，
her, but she's not speaking the same love language as me. So to her, she feels unloved by her own sister. And we're best friends. And that's when I realized, Karen, what's your love language? And she said, what are you talking about? I said, Karen, just do the test, the random free test on Google. You know your love languages. I think that's where we have the issue. So again, I put my ego aside to figure out, instead of taking what she said personally, to understand, how can I make my sister feel loved? And that's when I realize for her, what is it, physical touch and quality time or her love languages. So we are, they're the pandemic.
但她并没有使用和我相同的爱语。对她来说，她觉得自己连亲姐姐的爱都感受不到。而我们可是最好的朋友。就在那时我意识到，卡伦，你的爱语是什么？她说，你在说什么？我说，卡伦，去做个测试吧，就是谷歌上那种随机的免费测试。你知道你的爱语是什么。我觉得问题就出在这里。所以再次地，我放下自我去弄清楚，与其把她的话当成针对个人攻击，不如去理解：我该怎么做才能让我的姐姐感受到爱？就在那时我意识到，对她来说，是什么呢——身体接触和质量陪伴是她的爱语。所以我们在大流行期间，
So we can do quality time. So she's missing that. And I mean, physical touch. And the quality time, I'm not, I'm so busy with work. That's not priority for me to answer people's sex right away or to call. So I'm doing what I know best, which is, hey, you're doing great. great or you look so cute in that outfit because that works for me. But for her, it's shallow.
我们无法享受质量陪伴。所以她缺失了这一点。还有，身体接触。至于质量陪伴，我也没有，我工作太忙了。马上回复别人的信息或打电话不是我的首要任务。所以我做的是我最擅长的事，那就是：嘿，你做得真棒，或者你穿那套衣服真可爱，因为这对我有用。但对她来说，这太肤浅了。
So once I realized that, my phone's always on do not disturb, but with my sister, I removed that. So she texts me, I answer right away. I always call her. I check in with her. Now the pandemic's over. I make sure to spend time with her because I know that's what's important to her. Is it one of my, it is technically one of my love languages now.
所以一旦我意识到这一点，我的手机总是开着请勿打扰，但对于我姐姐，我取消了这个设置。她给我发信息，我会马上回复。我总是给她打电话。我随时关注她。现在大流行结束了。我确保花时间陪她，因为我知道这才是对她最重要的事。这算不算我的爱语之一呢？它现在在技术上确实算是我的一种爱语了。
But in the past, was it? No. But because I knew that's how she felt loved, I made the effort to do that. So I think it's the same thing with couples as well. You should ask each other or your friends, what are your love languages? And even if those are not your love languages, then you can put the effort to make the other person feel loved. Because it's so sad the fact that all these years growing up with my father, he did his best in his own way to show me that he loved me. And I was this lonely child thinking, what does my father hate me so much?
但在过去，是吗？并不是。但因为我知道那是她感受到爱的方式，我付出了努力去做这件事。所以我觉得情侣之间也是一样的。你应该问问对方或你的朋友，你们的爱语是什么。即使那些不是你的爱语，你也可以付出努力让对方感受到被爱。因为令人难过的是，这些年来我和父亲一起长大时，他用他自己的方式尽了最大努力向我展示他爱我。而我却是个孤独的孩子，心想，为什么我父亲这么讨厌我？
You know? Yeah, that's so rough, I think. But it shows a great maturity and I think self-awareness to recognize that your love languages aren't just for what you need, but therefore what others want to receive from you as well. And you have to adapt them to different circumstances, especially in relationships where you really love the person. And I think a familial and a sister relationship is such a good example of that, where it's like, okay, I feel like sometimes love languages don't really apply in like the early stages of dating,
你知道吗？是的，这真的很艰难，我觉得。但这展现了极大的成熟度和自我意识，认识到你的爱语不仅是为了满足你的需求，也是为了满足其他人希望从你这里获得的爱。你必须根据不同的环境调整它们，尤其是在你真正深爱某个人的恋爱关系中。我觉得家庭关系和姐妹关系就是一个很好的例子，你会觉得，好吧，我觉得有时候在约会早期阶段，爱语并不太适用，
if you're not like committed to each other. But when it comes to those like lifelong relationships that are always going to be by your side, it's worth really acknowledging like where your capacity for showing love and the kind of love you show has come from and how it can change over time. Because I also agree. I do believe that it will change. And there are certain people in your life who will change that for you. Like I think I was always someone who I thought my love language was like physical touch and words. affirmation and then I had this boyfriend who was so generous with me and would always give me
如果你俩还没有做出承诺的话。但当谈到那些将永远陪伴在你身边的终生关系时，真的很值得去认可：你表达爱的能力和展现爱的方式究竟源自何处，以及它如何随时间而改变。因为我也赞同。我相信它确实会改变。你生命中的某些人会为你改变这一点。就像我觉得我以前总是那种认为自己的爱语是身体接触和肯定的话语的人，然后我遇到了一个对我很慷慨的男朋友，他总是送我
gifts that he'd really thought about. And I always felt so awkward about receiving those. And I was always like, oh, no, no, no, no. Like, this is weird. This is like, what are you doing? You bribing me? Like, what's happening? Are you bribing me? I don't know. I just, I wasn't used to it. I was like, worse. Yeah, I was like, this actually makes me uncomfortable. And then he was like, no, I'm actually just doing this because I love you. And I was like, and then it completely changed. I'm much better at receiving gifts from people when they've really thought about it. It was the only way he knew how to express himself. Yeah.
他真正用心挑选的礼物。我每次收到这些时都会觉得很尴尬。我总是说，哦，不，不，不，不。这太奇怪了。这算什么？你在贿赂我吗？这到底是怎么回事？你在贿赂我吗？我不知道。我只是，我不习惯这样。我当时觉得，更糟糕的是。是的，我当时想，这真的让我很不舒服。然后他说，不，我其实只是因为爱你才这么做的。我说，然后这一切就彻底改变了。当别人真正用心挑选礼物时，我更善于接受了。这是他当时唯一知道的表达方式。是的。
And it was so sweet. It was really sweet. He like, yeah, he was a good boyfriend. Shout out to that boyfriend. He was a goodie. Before we wrap up, I do want to ask just like one final question here because I feel like a lot of what we've spoken about today is navigating our childhood wounds and these versions of our younger self that we have to adapt and bring into our current.
而且这真的很甜。真的很甜。他就像，是的，他是个好男友。向这位男友致敬。他真是个好人。在我们结束之前，我确实想问最后一个问题，因为我觉得我们今天谈论的很多内容都是关于如何应对我们的童年创伤，以及我们必须去适应、融入并带入到我们现在生活中的那些年轻自我的版本，
and understand and love. So what would you say to your younger self, that little girl who didn't feel particularly loved or seen by her father or any of those versions of you? I guess what I would tell my younger self, I would tell my younger self that all the things in that moment that I think are important and matter will not matter a couple of years from now, whether it was dying to be popular in high school,
去理解和爱它们。所以，你会对年轻时的自己说些什么，对那个没有从父亲那里感受到太多爱或关注的小女孩，或是对你过去的任何一个版本说些什么？我想我会对年轻时的自己说，我会告诉年轻时的自己，在那个时刻我以为很重要、很紧要的所有事情，几年后都会变得毫无意义，无论是极度渴望在高中时变得受欢迎、
to be seen, the boys that I thought were cool, the guys that I was dating, then none of them will matter. And wanting to get love from people that never loved me, that all that would not matter as long as love myself. I think the biggest lesson I could have given my younger self is that no one else knows what they're doing. And everyone else is just as insecure as you are. That's the biggest lesson that I would take away. And it took me a lot of years to learn that no one else, everyone else is a loser just like you. Because first you're like, I'm the biggest loser in this room.
然后你会想，等等，不对，这个房间里的每个人都是个窝囊废。根本没有人把你放在心上。此刻根本没有人想着我。没有人评判我。根本没有人把你看在眼里。你知道吗？这太美好了。这太棒了，因为这样我就可以四处走走，过我的人生，做我想做的任何事，因为根本没有人会在意。
And then you're like, wait, no, everyone else is a loser in this room. no one is thinking about you. No one's thinking about me right now. No one's judging me. No one gives a shit about me. And you know what? That's beautiful. That's amazing because then I get to walk around and live my life and do everything I want to do because no one gives a shit.
我们生命中有那么多时间都在过度在意别人的看法，直到有一天我们突然意识到，其实根本没有人把我们放在心上。他们关心的只是他们自己、他们的肠易激综合征、还有那个没有回他们信息的家伙之类的事情，他们根本没在想别的。他们才不在乎你忘记梳头呢。他们根本没有看你。明天，他们也不会记得这回事，因为他们满脑子都在想别的事。所以你打算把一整生都花在什么上面？停滞不前，什么都不做，就因为唯恐别人会评判你？
We spent so much of our lives caring so much what everyone else thinks until one day we realized that no one was ever thinking about us at all. They were thinking about themselves and their IBS and and, you know, the guy who didn't text them and whatever it else, they weren't thinking. They don't give a shit that you forgot to brush it. your hair. They weren't looking at you. And tomorrow, they're not going to remember that because they're going to think about something else. So you're going to spend your whole life what? Not moving forward, not doing shit because God forbid someone else is going to judge you.
去他的那些人吧。你知道吗，那些劝你不要做某事的人，往往正是那些自己没有勇气去尝试的人。所以我要对年轻的自己说，每个人其实都缺乏安全感，不要听信别人的话而认为自己做不到某事，或者认为自己不行。因为他们懂个屁啊！
Fuck those people. You know, who tells you not to do something is people that are too scared to do it themselves. So what I would tell my younger self is to everyone's so insecure and to not listen to other people to tell me that I can't do something or that I, or no. Because what the F did they know?
我完全同意。我的一个朋友前几天对我说过这样的话，真的让我深有同感。她说：那些过得比你好的人永远不会评判你。任何过得比你好的人都绝不会居高临下地评判你，因为他们懂的。你知道吗？这让我感觉，我真的很需要听到这句话。这让我感觉好多了。谢谢你这么说。我要把它记下来。这真的是个很好的建议。它真的改变了我的看法。你知道，我觉得，哇。我觉得我们两个都在网上，都有庞大的网络影响力，你有庞大的网络影响力，我虽然少一点，但也算有。
I totally agree. One of my friends said this to me, the other day and it really resonated. It was like, you will never be judged by someone doing better than you. No one doing better than you is ever going to judge down on you because they know. You know what? That makes me feel, I really needed to hear that. That makes me feel so much better. Thank you for saying that. I'm going to write that down. That was a really good advice. It really changed things to me. You know, I feel like, wow. I feel like both of us have online, a big online, you have a massive online presence, mindless, but still an online presence.
有时候人们真的很刻薄。是的。真的很刻薄。我当时正跟朋友聊这件事，她就对我说的那番话。她说：听着，这些人可没有你拥有的这一切。如果他们有的话，他们就不会说三道四了。你想想看，一个过得比你好的人会去批评你或贬低你吗？根本不会，因为他们并不缺乏安全感，他们不需要像我们之前讨论的那种“高罂粟综合征”那样，通过贬低别人来证明自己。
And sometimes people can be really mean. Yeah. Really mean. And it's just, it really, I was talking to my friend about it and she said that to me. She was like, listen, none of these people have what you have. If they did, they wouldn't be saying anything. Like, can you imagine someone doing better than you ever criticizing you or putting you down? It's like, no, because they're not insecure because they don't have that need to prove themselves by tall poppy syndrome like we were talking about before.
所以，是的，凯莉·詹娜才不会坐在那儿想：这真是一集愚蠢的节目。她更可能会想，好吧，听不听随你，再见，你知道吗？然后她就回去打理她那价值数十亿美元的公司了。没错。与此同时，我们却在这里像这样，任由一些小喷子毁了我们的一整天。所以记住这一点很有用。这真的是个很好的建议。很高兴你喜欢。
So, yeah, like Kylie Jenner's not sitting around thinking like, that's a stupid episode. She's more thinking, okay, don't listen to this or not, goodbye, you know? And then she goes back to her multi-billion dollar company. Exactly. Meanwhile, we're just here like, ah, letting little trolls like ruin our days. So it's a good thing to remember. That's a really good advice. I'm glad you liked it.
好吧，谢谢你来做客。不客气。非常感谢邀请我。老实说，这可能是我最喜欢的几期节目之一。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我希望此时此刻正在收听的每个人都能学到一些东西，享受这段节目，然后去收听《Almost Adulting》，并在Instagram上关注Daddy Issues，
Well, thank you for coming on. Of course. Thank you so much for having me. It was honestly probably one of my favorite episodes. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I hope that everyone who is listening right now learn something, enjoyed it, and that you go and listen to almost adulting and follow daddy issues on Instagram
因为这两者都是互联网上不可思议的绝佳角落。是的。非常感谢邀请我。《Almost Adulting》每周二和周四更新。我的个人单人节目或嘉宾节目通常在周四。我的短视频节目和更有趣的节目则在周二发布，各大平台均可收听。我是贝拉·本森。你可以在Instagram上关注我，还有我的表情包账号，即Daddy Issues下划线。
because both are incredible slices and corners of the internet. Yes. Thank you so much for having me. almost adulting is on every Tuesday and Thursday. My sole episodes or guest episodes normally Thursday. My short episodes and more fun episodes are Tuesdays available in all platforms. And then I'm Bella Benson. You can follow me on Instagram and then my meme account, Daddy Issues underscore.
是的。太搞笑了。我其实从我大概19岁、18岁起就一直在关注Daddy Issues了。真的吗？是的。那已经有一段时间了。我还记得我和朋友们在我还在慕尼黑的时候就很喜欢它。所以这真是一个圆满的时刻。
Yeah. It's so funny. I've actually been following Daddy Issues since I was like 19, 18. Really? Yeah. It would have been a while. I remember me and my friends really liking it back when I was in Munich. So this is full.
太搞笑了。对我来说真是一个奇妙的轮回时刻。谢谢大家今天的收听。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你觉得顺手的话，当然，这真的对节目的成长很有帮助。另外，欢迎加入我们的社区，在Instagram上关注我们@thatpsychology.podcast。我们接受节目建议。我们很期待听到你们的声音。
That's so funny. A circle moment for me. Thank you, everyone, for listening today. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. If you feel cool to do so, of course, it really helps the show to grow. Also, feel free to join the community and follow us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. We take episode suggestions. We'd love to hear from you.
和往常一样，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，祝你度过美好的一周。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，即数字TWO和%。
And as always, have a lovely week wherever you are. are in the world. And we will be back next week for another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是一个重要时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
84年是一个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全去进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何处理这些问题的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身铠甲？
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
还有两个男人经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证由人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。